six caches dans le bois quand lui
meunier part au parc national du fjord
du saguenay on a voulu répondre à cette
question
on expérimente une nouvelle technique
pour faire l'inventaire de la grande
faune et les résultats sont étonnants
[Musique]
les parks et les territoires qu on donne
agirait pour les générations futures
si on veut bien gérer un territoire il
faut savoir ce qu'on a dans
au parc national du fjord du saguenay
comme dans la plupart des parcs
les responsables de la conservation
veulent connaître l'état du territoire
quelle espèce y habitent et en quelle
quantité
donc c'est important pour nous qui
sommes des gestionnaires de parcs de
pouvoir dire ça on attend d'orignaux
puis peut-être de pouvoir valider dans
cinq ans dans dix ans est ce que notre
population est stable ce qui diminue
beaucoup
est ce que il ya un problème quelque
part quelque chose qu'on n'a pas détecté
on utilise depuis des années les mêmes
méthodes pour réaliser des inventaires
phonique des façons de faire qui ont
leurs limites pour les oignons fait des
inventaires aériens qui sont l'hiver
avec des avions donc on essaye de
compter ce convoi il ya des systèmes qui
sont tellement marquage capture ou
contact des animaux puis en fonction du
nombre de fonds les revois ta on est
capable d'évaluer une densité
mais toutes ces méthodes là sont
coûteuses ou pas trop précises quoi
est-ce qu'on pourrait procéder autrement
une fois sur la la petite touche là
c'est ce qu'a voulu savoir l'équipe du
parc national du fjord-du-saguenay lui
sont retirés suis là aussi c'est un
petit peu ça qu'un motivé en fait le au
départ ce projet s'est trouvée s'est
trouvé une technique qu'ils soient
précises qui soit non invasif
c'est-à-dire qu'ils ne dérangent pas la
faune
et puis qu'il ait su à qui souhaite
qu'ils soient facilement répétable dans
le temps sont des coûts est important le
projet pilote a débuté en juillet 2018
sur la rive sud de la rivière saguenay
dans le secteur de rivière éternité et
de l'anse-saint-jean l'objectif réaliser
d'un même coup l'inventaire des grands
mammifères du bac orignaux cerf de
virginie
ours et loups pour y arriver
une soixantaine de caméras comme celles
ci ont été installés de façon aléatoire
sur un territoire de 100 kilomètres
carrés parfois dans des conditions très
difficiles
[Musique]
on partait tous les jours avec notre aux
packs saclay fois c'était pendant
plusieurs jours avec la boussole gps et
puis on traçait à travers la montagne
les barres rocheuses qui comme on est
tenue dans le temps avec un planning
quand même assez serré de déploiement
caméras mais un qui fasse beau ou qu'il
fasse pas beau on était tout le temps
sur le terrain à l'automne les pièges
photographiques ont commencé à livrer
leurs secrets
on est encore au stade de l'analyse mais
les premiers résultats qu'on a sont
vraiment incroyables ces c'est
impressionnant de voir la quantité de
faune qui un peu partout en tout des
dizaines de milliers de photographies
ont été prises et elles révèlent que la
grande faune du parc se porte beaucoup
mieux que ce que laissait croire les
inventaires aériens déjà réalisé en
particulier pour ce qui est de la
population d'orignaux
on a une densité dorian on le voyait les
orignaux on voyait qu'ils avaient des
pistes partout des crottes partout mais
là on se rend compte qu'on a des photos
on en a à la pelle des petits des gros
des énormes et on a des loups énormément
des ours on a des photos de meute de
loups dont on pensait pas jusqu'à 14 17
loup en même temps toi c'est assez
impressionnant mais comment cette
méthode innovant d'inventaire phonique
fonctionne-t-elle mais actuellement on
est en train d'installer les caméras du
projet donc on installe une caméra puis
après on est super important c'est de
mesurer le connexion euros qu'est ce que
la caméra va mesurer pour être sûr de
poids après avoir les calculs précis
l'équipe du parc s'est inspiré des
travaux menés par différents chercheurs
dont ceux de l'université du québec à
rimouski
cette méthode d'inventaire par caméra
s'inspire des modèles basés sur les
rencontres aléatoires
[Musique]
pour réaliser une étude comme ça on va
générer des points de façon complètement
aléatoire sur une carte informatique
donc des centaines de points puis après
on va l'installer nos caméras sur ces
points généré au hasard
donc on peut imaginer que parks un
milieu fermé interview lequel les
animaux et place de façon plus ou moins
aléatoire et ils vont rencontrer de
façon aléatoire des caméra posée
aléatoirement pour appliquer cette
technique il faut aller chercher dans la
littérature scientifique la vitesse de
déplacement des espèces des données qui
ont déjà été recueillis par le passé
grâce à des colliers émetteurs dont les
animaux étaient équipés on voit que
quand on fait les calculs c'est
important nous connaître ces vitesses là
parce que c'est pas les mêmes choses
pour un loup parents qui à faire des
longs des grandes distances à chaque
jour versus un orignal qui avoir un taux
de déplacement plus faibles il ya
certains animaux qui vont passer devant
plusieurs caméras il ya des animaux qui
sont passés devant juste une seule
caméra mais la beauté des statistiques
c'est qu'on n'a pas du tout besoin de
savoir si c'est le même pas le même
c'est juste une photo qui compte
on fait tout d'un coup avec une caméra
en fait à la fois les ours les orignaux
les loups les chevreuils on peut tout
faire
donc c'est déjà un gain de temps et
d'argent incroyable puis elle n'est pas
si dur à mettre en oeuvre une fois qu'on
a bien compris sur la méthodologie nous
on a envie de le partager tout ça
énormément
la voyait tout seul avec ses résultats
le parc a maintenant entre les mains un
nouvel outil d'éducation et de
sensibilisation pour les visiteurs et
aussi pour les citoyens qui habitent à
proximité
on a présenté les résultats est le fruit
du travail de ce projet qui a été fait
les gens ont vraiment adoré faut le dire
c'est extraordinaire de voir les images
qui ont été prises avec ce projet là y'a
personne qui peut rester insensible à
sal les gens du milieu ont senti cette
ce qui se fait dans le parc en termes de
conservation ils ont apprécié parfois la
nature nous réserve bien des surprises
l'équipe du parc a appris qu'un orignal
avait été trouvé mort en bordure d'une
route en marge de l'expérience elle a
alors décidé de placer une caméra
simplement pour voir ce qui allait se
produire
et il a eu droit à tout un spectacle
[Musique]
on a vu une meute de loups arrivée puis
mangé l'orignal bon les corbeaux outre à
un moment on voit un ours qui arrive un
gros ours qui arrive et on voit encore
dans l'arrière-plan des loups donc là
j'y vois c'est impressionnant et un
moment donné on voit tout le monde qui
part en courant et dans la même minute
on voit deux agents de la faune
descendent du chemin pierre gadéa
carcasse contours ils ont jamais
conscience une minute qui à côté de huy
louer un ours et ses incroyables toi
donc ça veut dire que nous on se balade
dans le bois on voit rien mais en fait
eu une voix ils sont là et c'est comme
dit pas ce mec comme on intercale et on
nettoie pour la société des
établissements de plein air du québec
la sépaq l'utilisation de cette
technique représente une voie d'avenir
elle permettra de mieux connaître l'état
de la biodiversité sur les territoires
et de suivre son évolution au fil du
temps je dis pas que les anciennes
méthodes étaient peut-être moins fiables
mais on essaye toujours de chercher
l'outil qui va être le plus facile et le
plus précis alors là on a une nouveauté
qui nous amène qui demandent peut-être
au moment du déploiement beaucoup
d'efforts mais après par contre ça donne
une mine d'informations qui est
extraordinaire
les parcs nationaux de la pointe-taillon
au lac saint jean et du pic au bas saint
laurent ont testé la nouvelle technique
d'inventaire et ce n'est que le début
moi j'y crois beaucoup points des siens
il ya vraiment tous les paramètres qui
sont gagnants à faire ça donc on a
encore quelques petites retouches à
faire mais c'est vraiment une technique
d'avenir je pense au québec va se
répandre très vite dans l'avenir
au parc national du fjord du saguenay
l'inventaire par caméra a fait ses
preuves et personne ne veut revenir en
arrière
forcément quand on travaille dans un
parc national parce qu'on a une fibre
particulière avec le milieu naturel donc
de pouvoir effectivement découvrir
l'envers un petit peu de ce décor là là
on sait plus qui observent eux qui
finalement quand on se promène dans la
nature est de savoir que maya toute
cette faune autour de nous c'est c'est
un sentiment qui est vraiment incroyable
très agréable
donc il y a
il ya la faune a partout puis quand on
est capable de communiquer ça à nos
visiteurs
c'est là qu'on va aller chercher parce
que eux aussi apprennent à aimer
territoire et eux aussi vont de protéger
après
[Musique]